[Musique]
les professionnels du btp se sont réunis
autour de cyrille melchior président du
département mais aussi de la spl avenir
réunion ce mercredi 15 juin dans
l'hémicycle au programme de la rencontre
la présentation de nouvelles mesures de
renforcement du dispositif
d'amélioration de l'habitat il ya double
objectif déjà prendre en compte l'état
la situation des logements diffus privé
on parle de 17 mille logements à la
région qui soit zen et un état de qui
convient d'améliorer et cette première
réponse avec un plan mode à hauteur de
200 millions d'euros donc le cif rocchi
qui envoyait par le département mais en
même temps apporter de réponses à nos
entreprises avec la crise les crises
successives s'est injecté un courant
d'affaires de 200 millions au service
des artisans de la région c'est aussi je
pense plus que nécessaire et donc
aujourd'hui ça a été la première réunion
a été aussi l'occasion de rompre
l'isolément des partenaires et de
trouver des pistes d'amélioration à la
suite des concertations menées par le
département et la spla avec les acteurs
concernés deux évolutions majeures du
dispositif ont été actés
premièrement nous avons travaillé sur
l'amélioration du bordereau de prix ni
de l'entreprise elle est payé sur la
base d'un bordereau de bris et son
bordereau de prix n'avait pas été révisé
depuis 2013 eh bien nous avons travaillé
nous avons révisé ce bordereau de prix
qui a été réévalué de 26% et aux joies
du bain les entreprises sont plus
intéressés par ce que les prix ont été
réévalués compte tenu du contexte de
prix et de vie chère et bien des
entreprises peuvent dire aujourd'hui oui
notre bruit qui sera payé à l'entreprise
car elle est quand même en nette
amélioration de 26 poisson ça c'est
important le boudreau de brit air et
pour les entreprises qui ne peuvent pas
répondre tous corps d'état il y en a ben
pour qu'elles ne soient pas pénalisés on
lui a dit vous pouvez aussi vous
regrouper les entreprises qui ne font
qu'un conte d'état et bien peuvent se
regrouper de façon à pouvoir répondre
aux offres de travail que nous mettons
sur
là la table eh bien ces groupements
c'est aussi ça représente une innovation
le budget a également doublé ce sont 40
millions d'euros qui sont désormais
consacrés aux dispositifs d'amélioration
de l'habitat
[Musique]